this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 16. with Echo Charles and me
Jocko willink
also join us tonight Daryl Cooper
so here we go good evening to you guys
whatever
all right so I was reading I I don't
know I don't know what
um particular Wormhole I was down in
this situation but I was reading this
art I ended up reading this article
something called The Ash experiment run
by a psychologist
named Solomon Ash I want to say this is
like 19 early 1950s when this went down
and so we ran an experiment
which experiments are kind of underrated
and I think they used to be able to get
away with all kinds of stuff this one
isn't bad but they they clearly are
maybe that's a good maybe that's a good
one for for the unraveling podcast just
look at some gnarly psychological
experiments they're out there yeah our
medical experiments we get into Tuskegee
experiment yeah that's freaking nasty
feel a little bit of national shame for
a moment that's a horrible horrible one
um all right so this experiment was set
up like this uh they had eight people in
a room
seven of the people are actors or they
call them Confederates in in the
psychological world but they're actors
and one person out of these eight is the
subject of the experiment and so then
they get they get asked a question and
this this particular experiment what
they did was they they had
they they described it as a vision test
or a perception test and they had a line
by itself
and then there was three lines
separate separated from it but near it
and they were of different lengths and
they were numbered one two and three and
you look at the line that was by itself
and the question was which of the other
three lines
is the same size as the line that's by
itself so it's a real simple
straightforward test
and
that's what they do and they'd show them
a bunch of different lines and a bunch
of different other lines
and then they'd ask one at a time they
would ask okay which one is it is it one
two or three and they'd go down the the
the seating right so they're all sitting
at a desk like a like a long desk
they're all sitting there facing these
lines they put up the lines and then
they go left to right all right what do
you think and it's an actor and what do
you think it's an actor they all the
actors answer first and then they have
the actual subject of the experiment um
so sometimes the the actors would all
give the wrong answer
and
when they did that
guess what happened
30 something 32 35 37 of the time the
subject would give the wrong answer too
he would just get influence when they
when the actors gave the correct answer
there was only one percent it was
actually less than one percent deviation
less than one percent deviation
but when the actors you know when the
when the when the correct answer is you
know line number two and all the actors
go uh line number three line number
three line number three line number
three they get to the subject and the
subject would go up yep line number
three
five percent of the time
when it's when it's and and I saw the
images it's not
it's really clear there's there's not
much different here there's not much uh
not much debate about which one of these
lines is like this or which one of these
lines the correct answer
so
and they got to ask multiple times and
so 75 of the subjects so 75 of the
subjects conformed
at least one time so almost everybody
that went in there 75 percent
at least one time conformed uh they were
doing it over again you know 10 they'd
show you 10 things yeah
yeah
um
and then here's another point on this
when they ran the same experiment but
they would have one of the actors
out of the seven give the correct answer
that was enough to drop the percentage
down to only five percent instead of 35
percent
of of conformity
so they get done with the experiment
they did some interviews with the people
um and said well you know what were you
thinking why did you say this so there
was
um two prominent answers the first one
normative in normative influence meaning
I just want to be normal and if there's
a bunch of people that are saying
something like I don't want to stand out
that's that was most of it most of it
was that and then some of it was also
what you're talking about they called
informational influence which is look I
look it looks a little bit short to me
but you know if if Echo and Daryl are
both saying that's the you know I'm
they're probably right you know it's a
little bit of self-doubt and they
generally they can also genuinely
genuinely believe that the group is
right so they're just like oh I'm yeah
my depth perception's never been that
great or whatever my my eyes have never
been that great and so and the other
thing is you're right it's not that bad
in leadership strategy and tactics I
have an actual section in there that's
called conform to influence
and what I'm talking about in there is
you know you want to influence the team
to go in a certain direction
but you're not part of the team or you
do things that make you separate from
the team or they don't view they view
you as different you're not going to
have any influence over that team so you
have to sort of conform to influence you
have to conform to what they're doing so
that you can so you can talk to them and
you can you can they will listen to you
lately I've been talking a lot about the
fact that if you don't let anyone
influence if if I don't let Echo
influence me he's going to be much more
opposed to me influencing him but when I
allow him to feel like oh yeah you know
where you want to go to dinner and he
says oh you don't want to go to uh what
the steakhouse and I go well which one
are you I want to go to Fred's
Steakhouse hey man that sounds good and
and because I allowed him to influence
me now when I say you know hey after
that can we run and you know get some
get some rolls in at Jiu Jitsu and he's
like he's more open to it
more open to it because I allowed him to
influence me and now now he's being
influenced so there is there is some
good things about it I mean look we want
people to conform in many situations
as I read this there's a there's a
reason that I wanted to bring it up and
the reason I want to bring it up is
because it's just a little it's a little
thing it's a little it's another little
filter to put on not only on your
thoughts right because we have to look
out for our own tendency to conform
we have to we have to look out for our
own tendency to conform where we're like
wait a second oh I'm just going with the
flow here and we have to look out for
other people's tendency to conform we
have a tendency to perform there it's in
this situation kind of proves it
when we look at the My Lai massacre
you get to see both of these because
first of all it Conformity when they got
there
when they arrived when this when this
company soldiers arrived and started
this massacre it was just Conformity it
was hey that's I guess that's what we're
doing we're just going to start shooting
people and of course then it escalated
to
heinous you know mutilation and and rape
in the whole nine yards but it was it
was part of that's just Conformity you
know that's what we're doing okay
that being said that one officer uh Hugh
Thompson who's in the helicopter it went
down there saw it he went back reported
it to the commanding officer and the
commanding officer got on the radio and
was like stop
and boom they stopped so all it took was
you know the when they when they put one
actor that gave the right answer and
that dropped it down to five percent I
just wanted to bring it up that one one
person can stop something bad from
happening and you know whether it's
something bad you know some kind of
atrocity that's an extreme but you can
even be at a company in a business and
you start seeing a bad idea and people
are just kind of on board with it hey I
guess that's where we're going and all
it takes is for someone to say hey wait
a second why are we doing this what's
going on here
to to stop the group think to stop the
Conformity if it's going in the wrong
direction and I talk about Sony F online
the other day but I was talking a lot
about you know I you always hear me talk
about detaching you got to detach you
got to detach why do you gotta detach
you got to detach so that you can see
you can see
as a leader you want to detach so you
can see but
you've got to actually know what you're
looking for
if you just detach and look around and
you don't know what you're looking for
that doesn't really help too much you're
you're kind of hoping that you see
something but you have to be looking for
something and what there's a bunch of
things that I've been going over that
you can look for
but one of the things I've been talking
about or one of the things that I talked
about the other day is you've got to
detach and take a look at the momentum
of the group
and there's a chance that the momentum
is going in the right direction and
everything is you know everyone's just
excited about it and it's going to add
momentum and it's going to be great
because we're going to go even faster in
that direction that we should be going
and if you detach and you see that and
you measure it and you check the
direction of the momentum of the group
and it looks like it's going in a good
place cool you can let it continue to go
there
but you also have to pay attention
because there's a chance that that
momentum that the group is going in is
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground